こんにちはんはず3冊をです皆さんボンボン tv の4つでご存知でしょうか
金はですねたまに僕の家にも遊びに来てるんですけども今やもう本 tv をしている
猫ボスみたいな感じになったよっちゃあですよねそのボンボン tv のメンバーで
アジだからムーム者議員さんなのでは僕の一個下の後輩で富山県も同じ出山なんで御何
か僕のこと日
スペックとしてくれてるんですよすごく一さんはじめさんすごい僕のことをリスペクト
してくれるなら高元さんみたいな youtube になりたいですけれどと言って
くれて非常にうれしいんですけども
その気持ちは本物なのかその国に対するリスペクト成人は本番のなのかって言うと5月
どこが確かめようと思いましたインターネットで欠かせない存在すら何かわかりますか
そう
感じですネットの動画世界の流通じゃなくてもねもうどうにもアンチというものがいる
んですよねっとはで顔を隠してね好きなことを言えるからとの思ってもないことを言っ
てみたり気に食わない人がいたらとりあえず暴言吐いてみたりする人だってたくさん
いるんですけども僕にももちろんいると思うんですアンチが今回はですねもしその
アンチが僕の意を特定して路軍地まで入ってきて
僕を捕まえて母校にその夏して深めてどっか持って行こうとしたときにうるさいん県北
の後輩でありボンボン tv のリーダーたるよっちが同構造するとか本がちょっと
確かめてみると思います h がもうすぐ家に来るので4つと僕が僕山つけての
コンビニ行こう
一緒に歩いて墓群つの道開けた
時にそこからあっちが2人花を持ってことを吐露するそして捕まえに来た時に一緒にい
た4つはどう行動するのか今回は検証してみたいと思います4つ
よ俺を助けてくれ
で梅香
はぁ
goo ん
ここ
君を
rar
すっああああああああ
me
ni
ああああああ
me
ni
a 2
へええええええらー
日エラー
おじさーん
頭でございます決めちゃってる
ええええええ
ぶううううううっ
car
ああああああ
yeah
ちぃ
hey hey
ん
me
わー
わぁー
すーっ
pr 2
ふう時から0 moreno デー
me
うっうードゥ